Welcome students to the
Pharmacology of
Cholinomimetics.
There are two
lectures because of
two different types
of cholinomimetics
and this one
we will start
with is the direct
acting group.
Direct acting
muscarinic and
direct acting
nicotinic receptor
agonists, Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to chat about
pharmacology.
individuals and groups
are most welcome.
Here are learning
objectives. I've put
titles on each of these
learning objectives
to help you focus on
what they're about.
As you can see,
pharmacokinetics
and mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms.
The school requires
the Scholar Rx
Bricks. I require the
practice questions,
All else is
completely optional.
Learn however you
like to learn.
I'm providing this
lecture video, word
handout, guided reading
questions to help
you focus on what it
is you need to know.
And you can
look at what is
nice to know if you wish.
here are links
i've indicated the
the review books
that have practice
questions in them if
you like to use those
we'll talk about the
autonomic nervous
system first it's
impossible to really
understand the pharmacology
of cholinomimetics
and pathomimetics
and the receptor
blockers without
understanding the
functions of the
autonomic nervous system.
Touch one place and
the entire nerve
web is affected.
Just as if you were
to touch one spot
on this lovely
spider web, the entire
web would shake.
I'm providing key
points, you may use
them or not, depending
on if it helps you.
It is really the need
to know information.
What is it I
need to know?
It's in the key points.
Let's start though
with some tips for
studying the pharmacology
of the autonomic
nervous system.
Students always ask me,
how do I learn
pharmacology? and you'll do
it however works for
you, my suggestion
is always to start
with the big picture.
Excuse me.
I'm going to use
my arrow to point.
The big picture.
Why are they used?
How will they
achieve the desired
therapeutic outcomes?
This goes back to the
mechanisms of action.
And what is the
common thread that
connects all of them?
Begin with the
class actions.
That's always my
suggestion. Class actions.
Get the big picture
first. All of the
drugs are going to
reflect the class actions.
So if you learn that,
it's pretty much
the same for all the
drugs in the group.
Now there will be
some drug-specific
effects, generally
one or two, usually
on the pharmacokinetics,
and if you've
already learned the
class actions, it's so
much easier to learn
those one or two
differences for the
drugs that I have put
stars on that you
need to know by name.
definitions are
so important for
understanding
anything at all to
to be comfortable with
the language that's
being used in this
case the language of
medicine the language of
science the language of
pharmacology will
help you to understand
and help you to communicate
with others, put
titles on these
key points also to
help you recognize
right away what
is in the content
of the slide.
So we started out with
the neurotransmitter
acetylcholine. Now
we're moving to the
receptors and the
actions of the drugs
because the drugs are
going to behave like
acetylcholine. They are
cholinomimetics. They
will mimic the
neurotransmitter actions.
And then some
properties of the
drugs, uses and
adverse effects.
And that brings us to
the actual beginning
of the lecture. The
indirect cholinomimetics,
as I mentioned
in the beginning,
will be described in
the next lecture, and
the remaining autonomic
nervous system
groups of drugs will
be in later lectures.
So let's take a
quick look at the
autonomic nervous
system functions.
This is the kind of
big picture view.
On On the left-hand side
of this figure, here,
is the sympathetic
division,
and on the right
-hand side is
the parasympathetic
division.
Acetylcholine is the
neurotransmitter for
all cholinergic
neurons, and the
parasympathetic division
uses acetylcholine for
its neurotransmitter.
But that's not all.
The acetylcholine is
a neurotransmitter at
the ganglia, at the
nicotinic receptors.
And there's
two exceptions.
It's a
neurotransmitter in the
sympathetic nervous
system at the adrenal
medulla and in
the sweat glands.
Now, the enteric
nervous system is
regulated by the
sympathetic and
parasympathetic nervous
system. It is the
parasympathetic side
that predominates.
That said, the
enteric nervous system
really is called a
second brain. It's
self-contained. It
works on its own.
It has many, many,
many neurons in
there with different
neurotransmitters.
And as I said, it is
the autonomic nervous
system that regulates
the function.
Looking now at
where these nerves
emerge from the
spinal column,
looking first at the
parasympathetic
nervous system,
they come out of here,
this portion right here,
and out of the sacral
portion right here.
The sympathetic
nervous system
comes out of the
thoracic portion
down to the second
lumbar vertebra.
The parasympathetic
has long pre-ganglionic
neurons and short
post-synaptic neurons
which join at the
effector organs. Now, the
sympathetic has short
preganglionic neurons.
I see ganglia here,
ganglia here, these
circles, and long
postganglionic neurons.
And all of
these organs are
innovated by
both systems. Now
a really, really
simplified version
so I can talk about
the receptors.
The somatic system,
so this is our motor
neuron here, and
this is our skeletal
muscle figure here.
Here is acetylcholine,
so that's a
neurotransmitter, and it's
nicotinic receptors here
at the neuromuscular
junction, so
nicotinic receptors.
Parasympathetic come out
of the cranial
and spinal,
sacral especially.
Synapse, so we have this
long presynaptic neuron,
synapse at the ganglia,
and this is synapses
at all the ganglia.
See down here too.
Then this short
postsynaptic neuron with
acetylcholine,
neurotransmitter, and the
neuron will synapse
with the effector
organs. So the
effector organs in the
parasympathetic nervous
system are smooth muscle,
so we have smooth
muscle all over, cardiac
tissue, and secretory
glands, glands
that secrete, and
we'll be talking about
the various substances
that get secreted.
There is an exception,
and that is the
sweat glands are
cholinergic, but
they are on the
sympathetic nervous
system. So here we
have the sympathetic.
We have the neuron
going to the adrenal
medulla, but it is
a nicotinic type,
and this is NN,
that means neuronal.
This is NM, that
means neuromuscular.
here we have the
ganglia, which again
is the acetylcholine,
so it's a cholinergic
neuron going to the
ganglia, neuronal
nicotinic receptor
there, and these
long postsynaptic
neurons going to the
effector organs. And
norepinephrine is
the neurotransmitter
at the effector organs
acting on alpha
and beta receptors.
Acetylcholine
to the sweat
gland, which
is muscarinic.
The receptors of the
parasympathetic system,
the cholinergic receptors
of the parasympathetic
system, are muscarinic
receptors, M.
Whereas, as I
mentioned, at the
adrenergic side, which
is the sympathetic
side, are alpha
and beta receptors.
And it is a
muscarinic receptor
at the sweat
glands. I put a
picture here of
the adrenal glands.
Adrenal, they sit
on the kidneys.
And there are various
things secreted from
there. But we're talking
about epinephrine
and norepinephrine,
which are secreted from
the adrenal medulla
chromophane cells into
the bloodstream, and
then they travel to
the effector organs
through the bloodstream.
Let's take a
closer look at the
receptors. This is
really a kind of a
generic look at
receptors. we're going
to be talking
about ion channels.
This is the spot
where the ligand
will bind. The
ligand-gated ion
channel would likely
be on two sides.
The channel opens and
ions pass through.
This is a G-protein
coupled receptor. You
can see seven passes
through the membrane.
And we have our
G protein down
here with its
components, alpha,
beta, and gamma
components.
These G proteins
are connected to ion
channels. So these are
G protein connected ion
channels, which when
activated will open.
the agonist binds
activates the alpha
and beta gamma
components separate
and then the second
messengers are
activated and on and
on that's a basic
idea so let's start
talking now about
the cholinomimetics,
but first we need
to understand
acetylcholine. You can
see it's a very simple
molecule and it's
got a quaternary
ammonium group on it.
Quaternary 1,
2, 3, 4 bonds
and a positive charge.
It is synthesized within
the presynaptic neuron.
Choline will pass through
the choline transporter.
Acetyl-CoA will
donate an acetyl group
to the choline
making acetylcholine.
It will then be
stored in the vesicle.
It gets into
the vesicle by
this vesicle
-associated transporter.
And it will stay stored
inside the vesicle
along with other
neurotransmitters, whatever
is necessary for that
particular neuron.
And when an action
potential comes
down, it will
cause opening of
the calcium
channel here on the
presynaptic neuron,
plasma membrane.
Calcium will go in, the
vesicle will move to
the membrane, and this
is actually already
showing you here where
it's invaginated. So
just imagine this is
the vesicle has moved
down here, and the
membrane has opened, and
the contents are exocytosed
into the synapse.
These receptors
here, which
happen to be in
a green color,
and here on the
presynaptic neurons,
so postsynaptic,
presynaptic, will
then be activated
by acetylcholine.
And as acetylcholine
diffuses that, it
will activate the
presynaptic neurons.
The artist placed
them here on the
membrane, but that
doesn't mean they're
necessarily way out
there. They could be
much closer in. And
there aren't going to
be just one or two
or three or four.
There are many, many,
many receptors that
are expressed on the
plasma membranes.
So we get our
postsynaptic action
and our presynaptic
effects.
This receptor
that is colored in
blue is labeled as
other receptors.
So there are not only
muscarinic receptors,
and these are
obviously G proteins
here, but there are
other types of receptors
that are also expressed
on the neurons.
This figure here
on the postsynaptic
membrane, that looks
to me anyway like
a vase with flowers
in it, is labeled
as acetylcholine
esterase. It is this
enzyme that will
inactivate acetylcholine.
It has an extremely
fast action.
Acetylcholine will
bind to the enzyme,
and the enzyme will
hydrolyze it
into choline,
which will then
be recycled back
to be formed again
into acetylcholine,
and acetate,
which will then
move out of just
a few of the way.
So that's basically
a very simple process
that the acetylcholine
synthesis,
storage, exocytosis,
action, and inactivation
by acetylcholinesterase.
Let's take a closer
look now at these
receptors that we're
talking about, the
specific types, the
nicotinic and the
muscarinic. On the
left-hand side is
the nicotinic
acetylcholine receptor.
It's an ion channel,
and it is ligand
-gated, meaning that
a molecule needs to
bind to it in order
to cause it to open.
this is a cutaway
here of the channel
it says alpha beta
delta alpha so that
would be a typical
nicotinic receptor
at our skeletal
muscle there are other
configurations of
nicotinic receptors
but the idea is still
the same acetylcholine
will bind and cause
it to open and cations
especially sodium will
move through this one
says neuronal this
one says neuronal they
have different
configurations but they're
still functionally the
same what i want to
point out is that the
acetylcholine receptor,
I mean, well, yes, I
guess you could call
it a receptor, where
acetylcholine will bind
is at the alpha subunit,
see, they're both alpha,
interface with the
neighboring subunit.
Same thing here,
alpha neighbor.
these are all alphas.
So they're all around.
Acetylcholine needs
to bind to two,
in this case, in
the neuromuscular
and this neuronal,
to both sites in
order to cause opening
of the channel.
Now, looking at
the G protein, it's
an interesting
figure, the way the
artist has shown it,
how the configuration
of it in the
plasma membrane.
Here we have the amino
side on the outside
and the carboxyl
side on the inside.
this indicates where
the g protein will
actually join up and
attach to the g protein
which is why it's
called to the receptor
which is called why
it's called the g
protein coupled
receptor now these are
called metabotropic
and that is because
they are also connected
to the ion channel
the muscarinic
receptors come in three
types m1 2 3 4 and 5
the odd numbered ones
m1 m3 m5 are all of the
gq variety of protein
coupled receptors
which means they
activate phospholipase
C, which then forms
inositol trisphosphate
and diacylglycerol.
Inositol trisphosphate
increases
intracellular calcium
levels, which then goes
on to cause effects,
and diacylglycerol
increases phosphokinase
C, respectively.
So an M2 and M4, the
even-numbered ones, are
the inhibitory type
of G-protein-coupled
receptors. So they
inhibit adenylacyclase,
which decreases
concentrations of cyclic AMP,
the second messenger,
which will, in turn,
increase potassium
conductance and decrease
calcium conductance
through their connection
to the ion channels.
Okay, so that's
all good. The
neurotransmitter
will activate the
receptors, and
then what happens?
These receptors
are located
really everywhere
in the body.
So think about how,
think about the relevance
using drugs now.
Drugs are going to
mimic the actions of
acetylcholine, which
means they're going
to have widespread
effects because
they'll affect the
muscarinic receptors
all over the body or
the nicotinic, depending
on what it is we're
talking about.
It is indicated in
this figure right here.
The top line says
red sympathetic
actions and the
second line says
blue parasympathetic
actions. So
let's just look
at the blue ones.
Eye, contraction of
the iris sphincter
muscle, so the
pupil will contract.
That means it
gets really small.
And contraction
of the ciliary
muscle. Now the lens
will change shape
to accommodate
for near vision.
So we can see up close.
Looking at the trachea,
the lungs, right
here in the picture.
the parasympathetic
system causes constriction
of the bronchi
so closes the bronchial
smooth constricts
the bronchial smooth
muscle causing the
bronchi to be closed
not closed definitely
but a smaller diameter
and increasing the
secretions so the
mucus will be secreted
so we have the
constriction and we have
increased like juicy
stuff in the bronchi.
Adrenal medulla No.
Kidney? No. So
now we're down
here to the
urinary tract.
The acetylcholine causes
the bladder to get
rid of the contents.
In other words, to
promote micturition,
to allow urination. So
how's it going to do
that? Well, imagine the
bladder is kind of like
a balloon with water
in it. If you squeeze
it, the water will
go out. So contraction
of the detrusor, which
is a muscle around the
bladder, contraction
of it is causing that
squeezing effect.
And relaxation of the
trigonin sphincter so
that the fluid inside
can be released out.
So micturition, the
ability to urinate.
In the male
genitalia, it causes
stimulation of ********.
In the eyes, back
to the eyes, I
should have gone back
and forth, but I
went down and up.
The lacrimal glands,
so tearing.
Salivary glands,
watery secretions, lots
of watery secretions.
the heart it causes
the heart to slow
down it decreases the
heart rate it decreases
the strength of
contraction it isn't
listed here but it
decreases the slows
down the conduction
through the
atrioventricular node.
In the GI system, it
increases the muscle
motility and tone,
and also it can
regulate the secretions.
Female genitalia, no.
Blood vessels
in the skeletal muscle.
That's going to be a
sympathetic
effect, so no.
And blood vessels
in the skin, mucous
membranes, and splanchnic
area, all of those
are controlled by the
sympathetic nervous
system. And I just
want to put a little
corollary on here that
I'll talk about later.
Okay,
so the sympathetic
nervous system
now will do basically
the opposite
pretty much of what
the parasympathetic
nervous system is doing.
In terms of drug
therapy, well,
the drugs don't know from
sympathetic or
parasympathetic.
Their action is
related to the affinity
of whatever receptors
they're intended
to act on. So if we
give a cholinomimetic,
a direct acting
cholinomimetic, that
means they act directly
on the receptors,
and it's acting
directly on muscarinic
receptors, it's also
going to activate sweat
glands. Even though
that's a sympathetic side,
it's a muscarinic
receptor, the M3 type.
There are also non
-neuronal receptors and
non-neuronal synthesis
of acetylcholine,
such as in immune
cells, and that's
just a little piece
of information to keep
under your hat.
I'm not going to be
dwelling on that much,
but the immune system
can also be regulated
by the neurotransmitters
of the autonomic
nervous system.
Eye. I'm going
to spend a couple
of minutes on
the eye. On the
left-hand side,
this is the orb.
You can see the orb. This
is the anterior portion.
Here's the lens.
Here's the iris.
this is mainly
showing you the blood
supply and lots of
vasculature in the eye
and that's important
because we're
sending our drugs
through the bloodstream
and they are going to
reach their targets
through the
bloodstream. Now let's
take a closer look
because we need to
be looking at the
receptors in the eye.
So this is a
cutaway. Here's
the cornea. This
would be the
cornea on this
larger picture.
This is a little
hole here that's
called the
canal of Schlem.
That would be the
canal of Schlem drains
into the venous
system and it's
located on the inner
portion of the eye.
It's a trabecular
meshwork. You
can see it looks
like this mesh.
The aqueous humer will
drain through this
mesh and into the
canal of Schlem, which
will then take it into
the venous system.
Now here's the
iris. This is a
rendition of the iris
and the sphincter
muscle, the iris
sphincter muscle,
that's going to
cause it to contract
and make a pinpoint,
a small pupil.
It has a
muscarinic receptor
on it. It's an
M3 receptor.
The dilator muscle,
which would cause the
pupil to open. Now
that's an alpha
receptor. That's on the
sympathetic side. So
we see the iris is
regulated by both the
parasympathetic and
the sympathetic side.
Looking at the ciliary
body. Here we have
the ciliary body up
here, but at least
the vessels of it.
ciliary epithelium
ciliary muscle smooth
muscle the smooth muscle
is innervated by the
parasympathetic system
and muscarinic receptors
the epithelium by the
sympathetic system
and beta receptors
so we will be talking
about the effects of
the cholinomimetics of
the sympasomimetics
of the blockers on all
of these various organs
including the eye.
The signaling in
the heart is really
important for
you to understand
because it's part
of the reflex
system controlled
by baroreceptors.
So if you understand
it you'll be able to
understand the reflex
reflex responses.
Here we have the heart, a
plasma membrane
in heart tissue.
This is the sinoatrial
node, so that's
a pacemaker.
Here we have a muscarinic
receptor and
it's labeled M2.
Acetylcholine
activates the M2 receptor
at the sinoatrial
node. M2, remember,
is inhibitory and
that will cause slowing
of the heart rate.
It is the sympathetic
side that is
the predominant
effect in the heart.
slowing of the heart rate
and also it will
slow conduction
through the AV node
the same action
slow the heart rate,
slow conduction
through the AV node
and reduce the force
of contraction
that's not shown here
now looking at the motor
neuron here in panel B
activation of
the nicotinic
receptor there in
the motor neuron
if strong enough will
activate an action
potential it's called
an end plate potential
and we have that indicated
here and that will
cause contraction of
the skeletal muscle
and And now, here
is the vasculature.
This is an
interesting idea.
Acetylcholine
receptors are
located on
endothelial cells in
some areas of
the vasculature.
This is not innervated
by the parasympathetic
nervous system.
This is one of those
non-neuronal
acetylcholine receptors.
activation of the
receptor it's an m3
receptor will cause
the synthesis of nitric
oxide nitric oxide
is a powerful
vasodilator so nitric
oxide that's been
synthesized in the
endothelial cells will
passively diffuse to
the smooth muscle of
the vessel and that
will cause vasodilation
That's the takeaway
from all of this.
You don't have
to remember all
of the rest of
it. That's what
I, this is the
part to remember.
Acetylcholine non
-neuronal receptor M3 on
endothelial cells causes
synthesis of nitric
oxide, activation of
nitric oxide synthase,
which will then passively
diffuse into the
smooth muscle of the
vasculature causing
vasodilation. Now, if
we were to inject a dose
of acetylcholine
intravenously, which we do
not in clinical medicine,
that would actually
cause this effect
that I just described.
We don't give
these drugs IV. We
don't give choline
-omimetics IV.
So we don't tend to see
this effect
with the drugs.
Now, I mentioned
before reflux
responses and
local integration.
Here's our neuron again.
Here's our
postsynaptic neuron.
So local integration.
Feedback by
modulatory autoreceptors,
heteroreceptors
on the presynaptic
nerve. nerve.
So I draw your
attention to this
area here that
I'm circling.
The autoreceptor
means that it is
the type of receptor
of that neuron.
It's a self-receptor.
So this would
be an M2 receptor
in the periphery.
Activation of this
presynaptic M2 receptor,
which remember is
inhibitory is going to
inhibit the release of
the neurotransmitter.
If this muscarinic
receptor were located,
let's say over here,
on a neighboring
sympathetic neuron,
it's still an M2
receptor, but it's on
a different system.
It's on the sympathetic
system, so it
becomes a heteroreceptor.
It's the same
muscarinic, M2 receptor,
activation of it by
acetylcholine going
over to the neighbor
will reduce the
exocytosis of that
neurotransmitter. Let's
say norepinephrine.
We see a heteroreceptor
here. It's the same
concept. Let's say
that this is an alpha-2
adrenergic receptor.
adrenergic, meaning it's
a sympathetic nervous
system. Now, if this
neighboring neuron right
here that you can't
see that I'm just
indicating here with this
red pointer is a
sympathetic neuron and the
action potential causes
exo-diastosis of the
neurotransmitter
norepinephrine and
norepinephrine come manages
to diffuse over to the
neighbor here to the
heteroreceptor alpha 2
it's still going to be
the same action that
alpha 2 is on the
sympathetic side but it
is going to reduce
the the exocytosis of
acetylcholine so hetero
just means different
auto means same hetero
means different.
Systemic reflexes,
homeostatic mechanisms
that regulate blood
pressure, gastrointestinal
motility, bladder
tone, airway,
smooth muscle, and
other processes.
Remember I said before
that the sympathetic
nervous, the
parasympathetic does all of
these various things.
It causes secretions,
it causes smooth
muscle contraction.
the sympathetic nervous
system tends to do
the opposite so it would
cause vasoconstriction
relaxation of
smooth muscle in the
bronchi and we'll go
into more detail in
that when we get there
to the sympathetic
nervous system but
the point is they have
opposite effects they
regulate each other.
Now, let's say that
there is a drop in blood
pressure that's detected
by the baroreceptors
in the carotid
arteries and the aortic
arch. That will
send a signal to the
sympathetic nervous system
in the CNS to increase
heart rate and the
force of contraction
in response to this
drop in blood pressure.
So that would be a
reflex. On the other
side, if there is an
abrupt increase in
blood pressure due
to vasoconstriction,
the same idea happens.
The CNS will now
send a message to
the parasympathetic
system, which will
travel down the vagus
nerve, activate the
M2 receptors, and
cause the heart
rate to slow down,
conduction through the
AV node to slow down,
the force of contraction
to be reduced,
which will reduce
the amount of blood
cardiac output being
put into the vessels.
So that will help
to reduce the blood
pressure. So that's
a reflex response.
Please remember the
nervous system is
interconnected, it's
intricate, and it
ensures that the
body maintains
homeostasis and
appropriate responses to
various stimuli.
That's the whole point.
So let's check the
check your knowledge.
What is the definition
of cholinergic receptors?
What are the
cholinergic receptor
subtypes. Where
are they located?
So what's the definition?
Acetylcholine is
the neurotransmitter
for nicotinic and
muscarinic receptors.
Nicotinic receptors
are ligand-gated
ionotropic receptors.
Sodium, potassium,
and sometimes calcium
moves through them.
Muscarinic receptors
M1, 2, 3, 4,
and 5 are G
-protein-coupled
receptors located
on effector cells
M1, 3, and 5 are
postsynaptic GQ-type PCRs
and M2 and 4 are
actually the presynaptic
inhibitory type auto
- and heteroreceptors.
Where in the body
are they located?
Nicotinic
receptors in the
periphery are
located at all ANS
ganglia, the
adrenal medulla.
Muscarinic receptors are
distributed really
basically lots of
places, heart,
blood vessel,
certain blood vessels,
bronchi, GI tract,
urinary tract, salivary,
lacrimal, mucus,
and sweat glands.
Nicotinic and all
types of muscarinic
receptors are distributed
across various
regions of the CNS and
non-neuronal cells,
such as immune cells
and endothelial cells.
So let us get down to
the actual pharmacology.
Direct acting and
indirect acting. So
let's talk about
the direct acting in
this lecture. We'll be
talking about actions
directly on
muscarinic receptors,
actions directly on
nicotinic receptors.
Muscarinic receptors
get their name
from this mushroom,
which contains muscarine,
and it will bind
all types of
muscarinic receptors,
but no other types.
the this is pilocarpus
plant and this is
where pilocarpine
comes from which is the
prototype of the
choline omimetics so
choline esters are
acetylcholine we saw that
Methacholine,
carbachol, and
bifenicol. And the
tertiary amines
are pylocarpine,
the prototype,
and sevimeline,
which is the
synthetic tertiary amine.
I have stars on all of
them. It's
only six drugs.
If you think about
them by their
groups, it's really
only two groups, but
they do basically
the same things.
the structure activity
relationship matters
with these drugs it's
very easy to see why
they act the way they
do so the quaternary
part we see that here
they all have that part
and that's going to be an
important structural
feature when
when we get to
the mechanism
Then they have various
changes within the
structure. Here's this
simple acetylcholine.
Methycholine just
merely is a methyl
group attached here
at the beta point.
Carbacol just has this
difference right here.
This is a carboxyl group.
This one has
a nitrogen in
it, so it's a
carbamyl group.
And bethenacol has both.
B for both.
And methylcholine because
it's got a methyl group.
Methanichol B for both.
And carbachol is
just the carbamol. So
maybe that'll help
you remember them.
Now the tertiary
amines have only three
bonds here at the
nitrogen. One, two,
three. That's why
they're tertiary.
Pylocarpine
and sevimeline.
Okay, so how does
this change anything?
Well, acetylcholine,
as we know, is going
to bind to nicotinic
receptors and
muscarinic receptors,
and it's going to
be degraded by
acetylcholine, esterase.
Methacholine,
that's here, is more
resistant to
cholinesterase hydrolysis,
so it has a
little bit longer
duration, quite a
longer duration.
It doesn't have
very much nicotinic
activity actually,
but it's the only
difference in the
structure compared to
acetylcholine. Now
here's carbacol down
here and bethenicol.
Both have this
mammal group and that
will make them even
more resistant to
cholinesterase hydrolysis.
The carbacol, which
does not have this
methyl group,
has very strong
nicotinic activity as
well as muscarinic.
Bethanacol has really
only muscarinic activity.
And, as I said,
this cholinesterase
resistance to hydrolysis.
Pylocarpine is not
metabolized by
cholinesterase.
It's metabolized
in the liver,
and it has virtually no
nicotinic activity
like muscarine.
So those are the
features, structural
features, to
remember as we go
along and talk
about these drugs.
Cholineesters are
hydrophilic. We could
see that with the
quaternary ammonium.
Therefore, they're
not well absorbed from
the GI tract. They do
not cross into the CNS.
They are rapidly
eliminated in
the kidney. They're
water-soluble.
Only bethenagol is oral,
and a big dose has
to be used in order
to get enough of it
through the GI tract,
through the kidney,
through the liver,
and into the
systemic circulation.
Tertiary amine, pilocarbine
is well-absorbed.
It's not a hydrophilic
compound like
the others. It does
cross the blood-brain
barrier. So it's going
to have CNS effects,
and hepatic
metabolism, as well
as some esterases
in various tissues.
It is excreted
in the urine.
Sevumeline, it was
designed actually
to have more limited
CNS ***********.
It is well absorbed
and metabolized in
the liver, excreted
in the urine. Pretty
typical pharmacokinetics
of drugs.
Okay.
Muscarinic agonists
on M3. Now these
are not selective
for M3, but the
therapeutic uses
are aimed at M3.
Acetylcholine we
don't really use
clinically very
much because the
half-life is like
next to zero.
So it can be used
in the eye, and it's
used in ophthalmic
surgery. So Why
can we use it in
the eye? Well,
there's much less
acetylcholinesterase
in the eye than
there is in synapses.
So the acetylcholine
effect lasts
a bit longer.
Methycholine,
inhalation only.
So think now
for a second.
Well,
cholinomimetics
are going to cause
bronchoconstriction just
like acetylcholine does.
So why in the
world would we like
to induce
bronchoconstriction?
it makes it
hard to breathe.
Well, that's the
point, actually. It's
called a bronchoprovocation
diagnostic
challenge test, and
it's given in the event
that, as a diagnostic
for asthma, and
patients suspected
of having asthma. If
they have outright
asthma, there's no need
to give this
bronchoprovocation test.
So patients who
do have underlying
asthma are going
to be much more
responsive to this
bronchoconstricting
effect than other people.
And in fact, the
literature says that
it may actually be
the only evidence
of airway
dysfunction in that
individual with
asthma at that point.
It lasts for 30 to 45
minutes. Well, that's
a long time to have
the bronchoconstriction
on board. So a
reversal agent is
available. This is the
sympathetic side now.
A beta-2 adrenergic
agonist is going to
act on bronchial
smooth muscle and cause
relaxation. Open up
those bronchi again
carbacol topical eye
drops we don't give it
systemically because
it's got it would
have so many side
effects because of its
actions on both the
muscarinic and the
nicotinic receptors so
it's just used to lower
intraocular pressure
such as for glaucoma
or an ophthalmic
surgery for meiosis.
Bafenacol, I
mentioned before,
is the only one
that's oral.
It can be used
for urinary
retention due to
neurogenic bladder.
It has variable
effectiveness. Let's put it
that way. Sometimes
for some patients it
might be somewhat effective,
for other patients
not and it has been
used for acute post
-op and postpartum urinary
retention there may
be times when it is
still used but there
are other approaches
other strategies for
managing that now pilocarpine
that's the natural
alkaloid and prototype
it is given topically
as eye drops what's
it going to do
constriction of that of
the iris so meiosis so it
can be used for acute
angle closure glaucoma
which is a it's a
medical emergency surgery
is the treatment but
pilocarpine might
be used in the interim
it has been used for
a long time for chronic
open angle glaucoma
but there are so many
other drugs available
now they're so much
better okay i did say
that bathanacol was
the only oral it's the
only quaternary ammonium
compound that's oral
pilocarpine is oral
and it's called a
sialagog which
means it stimulates
the salivary glands
to secrete saliva.
Remember that watery,
copious saliva.
So that will help
in the treatment of
dry mouth, which is
called xerostomia.
There's a certain
autoimmune disease
called Sjogren's
Syndrome. That's
it right here,
Sjogren's Syndrome.
That causes dry mouth and
certain other symptoms.
Now there are other
treatments, such as
******* lemon drops.
that's sometimes
suggested. There
are over-the-counter
artificial salivas that
can be used. This is
an oral method in
case the others are
not effective for the
individual patient.
It has also been used
following
radiation therapy.
We're thinking
cancer there.
As long as the
salivary glands
are still
functioning. Okay.
Sevimeline, same
thing. That's
what it's used
for, ******,
for xerostomia,
and that's it.
So, these are our
quaternaries that are
used, these three,
and pilocarpine,
and sevimeline, the
tertiary compounds.
Okay.
Oops, I went
backwards. Sorry. Just,
okay, here we go. Adverse
effects. Well, think now.
These are going to
have actions at all
the peripheral
muscarinic receptors.
Pylocarpine is going
to have actions
also taken ******
in the CNS.
What are they? Well,
we have the lacrimation,
the salivary secretions,
bradycardia, and
bradycardia and
hypotension that
can cause a reflex
tachycardia if it's
an abrupt hypotension.
Dyspnea, trouble
breathing because
of the
bronchoconstriction.
So, think about
the cautions now.
What patients
might be harmed
by these adverse effects?
Bratocardia,
hypotension, reflex
tachycardia, or
bronchospasm.
People who had a
heart attack. People
who have uncontrolled
hypertension.
Aortic aneurysm because
of that tachycardia.
Urinary obstruction,
GI obstruction,
because we're causing
increased contraction
of smooth muscle,
increased movement of
those smooth muscles.
And that can make the
obstruction worse,
the consequences of
the obstruction worse.
Any kind of condition
that could be
adversely affected
by cholinomimetics.
Asthma.
Any kind of respiratory
disease. COPD.
Peptic ulcer
disease. Why peptic
ulcer disease?
Because of acid
secretion. Increasing
acid secretion.
Hyperthyroidism. Because
of the reflex
tachycardia.
And then GI and biliary,
urinary, GI biliary
and urinary obstruction,
obstruction.
We don't want those
GI muscles, those
various muscles
to be contracting.
Acetylcholine, well,
these are ophthalmic
issues that you
should, that's for
the surgeon. This
is used in surgery.
Methylcholine, well,
bronchospasm
can be severe.
So if you are going
to do or if you're
watching the
pulmonologist, the patient
should have an adequate
pulmonary function
test. And that's
referred to as an FEV1.
You can learn
about that later.
Carbacol, blurred
vision, carneal
edema, headache.
headache.
We're putting
in drops that
are going to
cause meiosis.
It can cause
corneal edema, and a
lot of eye drops
can actually cause
headache, at
least transiently.
Bethanacol oral.
So the blood pressure
decreased. Remember
that effect on the
vascular endothelial
cells causing nitric
oxide synthesis.
And if the blood pressure
should drop,
then tachycardia.
This doesn't always
happen, but we
need to be aware
that it could happen.
Bronchoconstriction, that
could definitely happen.
Sweating, diaphoresis,
activation of
muscarinic M3 receptors
on sweat glands.
Tearing,
salivation,
nausea, abdominal cramps,
urinary urgency
because of the effects
on the urinary
bladder to promote
micturition, to
promote urination.
Pylocarpine, again,
the blurred vision,
impaired vision.
We're putting those
drops in. They're
causing meiosis. We're
causing accommodation
to near vision.
And then the CNS
effects, the dizziness,
headache, a feeling of
generalized weakness.
And then the
peripheral cholinergic
effects on the
muscarinic receptors.
Sevimeline, same deal.
It's all the same. H1,
over and over and over.
So learn the
class effects,
and it applies
to all of them.
CNS effects, mainly the
pilocarpine. carping.
Check your knowledge.
Acetylcholinesterase
can hydrolyze 5,000
acetylcholine
molecules per second.
Why then is the
duration of action of
acetylcholine instilled
in the anterior
chamber of the eye
as long as six hours?
Because there is a
lower concentration
of acetylcholinesterase
in the eye.
An asymptomatic 60
-year-old patient
suspected of
having asthma has a
positive bronchoprovocation
test using
an ****** inhaled
cholinergic agent.
What are the mechanism
of action and
effects of the
administered drug?
I invite you to say
the name to yourself.
Administration of
methacholine by oral
inhalation activates M3
receptors and bronchial
smooth muscle causing
bronchoconstriction.
In patients with pre
-existing bronchial
hyperreactivity,
bronchoconstriction will
be provoked at lower
methacholine doses.
A patient with a negative
bronchoprovocation
test is unlikely
to have asthma.
Bronchoprovocation
testing may be useful
for assessment of
disease severity,
prognosis, and plan
of asthma treatment.
What are the
mechanism-related side
effects of muscarinic
receptor agonists?
Salvation,
upset stomach because
of acid secretion,
diarrhea,
abdominal upset because
of increased motility,
urinary frequency
and urgency
and even incontinence,
palpitations,
blurred vision, visual
disturbances and
drugs affecting the
CNS then drowsiness and
the feeling of muscle
weakness okay let's
go to the nicotinic
receptor direct
agonists direct acting
agonists pointed out
again we have our
nicotinic neuronal
nicotinic receptors here
at the adrenal medulla
and that causes
release of epinephrine
and norepinephrine.
We have it in both
ganglia, parasympathetic
and sympathetic,
and at the neuromuscular
junction. And
then, of course,
they're widely
distributed in the CNS.
Nicotine comes from
nicotiana tobacum.
I think you see
tobacco there.
and it has affinity
for all nicotinic
receptors but that's all
no muscarinic receptors
no any other type
of receptors let's
begin with nicotine
here we have a simple
structure again so
it is well-absorbed,
crosses the physiologic
barriers well,
crosses into the CNS.
There are lots of
formulations. It's
mainly not taken ******
because it's extensive
hepatic metabolism.
So CNS and
peripheral tissues,
all of these
various different
ways that it
can be taken.
I mentioned extensively
metabolized in the liver.
Cotinine, as you can
see, is an anagram
of nicotine, is a
major metabolite.
There are a bunch
of metabolites.
I'm going to jump down
here to the half-life.
Cotinine has a very
long half-life, and it
can be used as a biomarker
for nicotine use.
It doesn't have
nicotinic action.
The metabolites
go out through the
kidney. It is pH
-dependent. Nicotine,
like pilocarpine,
is an alkaloid,
which means it's
a weak base.
In a high pH,
much of it will be
reabsorbed. very little
will go out through
the urine. In a low
pH, and the urine
tends to be more
on the acidic side,
there's a greater
amount that is excreted
in the bladder,
less is reabsorbed.
What is the meaning
of that? Well,
not sure exactly,
but perhaps increased
concentrations of
nicotine stored
in the bladder
could be harmful.
Inhalation and nasal has
one to two
hour half-life.
Transdermal, four hours
because it's stuck
to the skin and it's
going to be delivering
the drug for a longer
period of time.
Biphasic effects. This
is a really important
concept that you must
take home with you.
Stimulation, a small
dose causes rapid
depolarization.
Remember, this is an
ion channel. Rapid
depolarization of the
postsynaptic membranes
where the nicotine
receptor, nicotinic
receptor is
located. And if it's
strong enough, it
will facilitate an
impulse transmission.
Now, high doses can cause
something called
a blocking effect,
the opposite effect
of stimulation.
It's called depolarizing
blockade and
this results from
prolonged agonist
occupancy and that
occurs from high doses.
Although membrane
voltage returns to the
resting level, remember
lots of nicotine
there in the synapse
causing this constant
activity at the nicotinic
receptor. So the
membrane voltage may
return to the resting
level, but that receptor
becomes desensitized
to the agonist. It
won't respond. It
becomes refractory. So
it's blocked. Its action
is blocked. And that's
called depolarizing
blockade. It will
initially open, but
then with this prolonged
exposure to the
nicotine, it will just
become desensitized.
Persistent depression
of all autonomic
ganglia, remember
where these are
located, and neuromuscular
junctions. In
the CNS,
they're located in
various areas, including
presynaptic,
prejunctional, and that
will cause
neurotransmitter release.
So why do people
use nicotine?
Because of the
pleasure reward
pathway that
gets stimulated.
And that nicotine, this
ionotropic receptor,
now think about
it in terms of
neurotransmitter release,
is going to cause the
release of dopamine,
of norepinephrine,
of acetylcholine, of
other amines, of amino
acids. So it's this
widespread effect.
It can cause
dizziness, tremor,
respiratory
excitation, vomiting.
This, of course,
is going to depend
on the dose and
whether or not the
patient is used
to the nicotine.
Large doses, we're
talking toxicity
now, can cause
convulsions,
respiratory failure,
convulsions, seizures,
and respiratory
failure, both at
the CNS level and by
depolarizing block at
the respiratory muscles.
And that, of course,
can lead to death.
Chronic exposure
causes an increased
density, an
increased number of
these nicotinic
receptors in the CNS.
peripheral effects
well think about the
ganglia both parasympathetic
and sympathetic
so activation of the
sympathetic remember
the vasculature is
not innervated by
the parasympathetic
it is only by the
sympathetic so activation
of the sympathetic
nervous system can
cause vasoconstriction.
Increased heart
rate, that's what it
does. Increased blood
pressure, that's going
to stimulate the
baroreceptors, and
that's going to cause
reflexive responses
to try and bring down
the blood pressure.
At the adrenal
medulla, it's
causing catecholamine
release.
So there, again,
sympathetic
effects in the gut.
Increased tone and
motor activity. Why?
Because it is the
parasympathetic side
that is the predominant
side in the gut.
And the glands,
it's going
to cause lots
of secretions.
and that would be
called caught followed
by inhibition when
there is depolarizing
block occurring so what
do we use the actual
nicotine as a drug
for smoking cessation
the point is to reduce
the cravings and
withdrawal symptoms
and it does work can
we use it in the
pregnant individual?
Well, the only evidence
we have of nicotine
in the pregnant individual
is from smoking.
And the incidence
of birth defects
following nicotine
replacement therapy might
be similar, but we
don't know. So we prefer
to avoid it. We
don't know, we avoid.
So what do we do for
the pregnant person?
Behavior.
Behavior therapy
is recommended.
Toxicity. Acute
toxicity. What are
we thinking about
here? Little kids,
especially little kids.
They're highly
susceptible.
Cholinergic excess,
central stimulation,
hypertension,
hypotension,
tachycardia, all this
sympathetic
stuff going on,
followed by hypotension
and bradycardia
because of the
depolarizing block.
Convulsions, death by
respiratory arrest.
That's both
central and at the
neuromuscular side, the
respiratory muscles.
So the depolarizing
block mechanism
to summarize
initial stimulation
of the central
autonomic and
neuromuscular
nicotinic receptors.
Prolonged agonist
occupation of the
receptors causes
persistent depression,
depolarizing blockade.
Blockade at the
motor end plate
causes muscle
fasciculation. So that's
like that jerky
kind of effect,
muscle weakness,
and that will
then go to
flaccid paralysis
and respiratory
muscle paralysis.
Let's talk about
varenicline now.
All right, so
that was nicotine.
Nicotine does what
nicotine does.
Berenicline was
developed to promote the
actions of nicotine
in the CNS, but
not to the same
degree, plus block
nicotine from binding
to those receptors.
And it's used
as a smoking
cessation aid
to reduce the
cravings and
withdrawal symptoms.
So that's the
big picture of
varenicline. Smoking
cessation is a
partial agonist of
these receptors.
Ah, well, it's a
partial agonist of a
component of these
receptors called the
alpha-4-beta-2 subgroup
on the neuronal
nicotinic acetylcholine
receptor. So
you can see there
it's more selective
than we see with
nicotine. the peak
pharmacokinetics this
is something called a
favorable pharmacokinetic
profile why
great bioavailability
taken ****** low
plasma protein binding
very limited hepatic
metabolism renal
excretion of unchanged
drug so renal dose
adjustment and a decent
half-life so it can
be taken once a day.
That's what makes
it favorable. All of
these together, all
these properties together
make it a so-called
favorable profile.
It can cause nausea, so
how do we mitigate that?
We advise the patient
to take it after
eating with a full
glass of water.
Of course, any drug
can cause allergic
reactions. And
CNS, you expect CNS
effects because that's
where it's supposed
to be working.
Headache, insomnia,
abnormal drains,
impaired physical
and mental abilities.
The incidence of adverse
pregnancy outcomes
following maternal
use of varenicline
is not greater than
the pregnancy outcomes
of pregnant patients
who smoke. So
that's how it's worded
in the literature.
What does that mean
for the pregnant
patient? That's
a discussion
you'll have. with
that individual.
Drug interactions?
Well, taking it with
nicotine. The whole
point is that it's
blocking the nicotinic
receptors so that
nicotine, I mean, it's
partially blocking,
so that nicotine
won't bind. And if
nicotine is used, it
can outcompete the
varenicline at the
nicotine receptors, plus
it can increase the
adverse effects.
Now, draw your attention
to this bottom
right here.
Alcohol may enhance
neuropsychiatric effects.
When the drug was
first approved, post
-marketing surveillance
suggested that there was
an increase in
neuropsychiatric effects in
individuals who were
taking varenicilline.
In other words, they
would have behavior
issues, they could be
even psychotic, and
alcohol would be
increasing these effects.
Aggression.
Since then, more
studies have been
done, appropriate
strong studies
have been done
that have shown
that varenicline
does not, in fact,
increase these
neuropsychiatric effects.
But when used with
alcohol, we may
see an increase
in them. So that's
the whole story
with varenicline.
Varenicline action,
this is just a figure
I found to try and
help you visualize how
the drug works. Here
are nicotine receptors
here, and we see various
neurotransmitters
have been, what's
the word I want,
have been released as
a result of binding
to the nicotine
receptors up here.
during prolonged period
of nicotine absence,
all of this goes away.
Here's the dopamine
down here, much less
dopamine release. So
this would be about
the cravings. If nicotine
is just withdrawn,
we have all of this
release causing
all of these cravings
and withdrawal
symptoms. Here's
varenicline, partial agonist,
also blocks nicotine,
and therefore we
have much reduced
dopamine being released,
but there's still
some, which will reduce
the cravings and
withdrawal symptoms.
And highlighted here
are the sites of action.
Where are nicotinic
receptors located?
CNS, ANS ganglia,
chromophane
cells of adrenal medulla.
What type of receptors
are nicotinic receptors?
Ligand-gated ionotropic
ion channels activated
by acetylcholine
binding to sites on
alpha subunits adjacent
to neighboring subunits.
I have seen that
particular piece of
information asked on
board review questions.
Opening of the
channels increases
permeability to
sodium, potassium,
and in some
cases, calcium.
A healthy adult patient
wishes to quit smoking.
What two drugs in this
category can
be recommended?
I'm hearing you
in my mind's ear.
Nicotine and varenicline.
Nicotine is
available in a lot
of different
products, including
vaping, and
varenicline is oral.
The difference is,
nicotine is a full
agonist, varenicline
is a partial agonist,
is alpha-4-beta-2,
and neuronal nicotinic
acetylcholine receptors.
They both help
reduce cravings and
withdrawal symptoms.
So what are signs
and symptoms
of nicotine? Toxicity,
cholinergic
excess, stimulation
of receptors on
affective cells,
CNS stimulation,
sympathetic excess
because of the stimulation
at the ganglia,
followed by
hypotension and
bradycardia because
of the polarizing
block of the
autonomic ganglia,
Seizures, death by
respiratory arrest.
And in summary, I put
everything into tables.
I hope that will
help you to review.
And the
parasympathetic system
is the rest and
digest side of
the autonomic
nervous system.